LIKE MARK SCHEIFELE LOOKING FOR
HIS 30TH GOAL OF THE
AWAY BY HELLEBUYCK.
BY WORK ALO
HELP OUT.
AND NOW WE'VE GOT S THEY
SCHEIFELE AND PICKED UP BY NEAL.
HE'S AWAY. GOES TO MORRISSEY. H.
RIFLES
PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS TO CONNOR.
HOOKED THAT BACK TO PIONK.
BACK TO KYLE CO
CONNOR'S THE SHOOTER WITH 41HIM.
HIS FIRST GOAL IN 9 GAMES. UP B
TKACHUK.
BRADY TKACHUK PLAYS IT AHEAD FOR
MATHIEU JOSEPH UP
BY ZAITSEV.
ZAITSEV HIT TO THE HEAD FOR
KELLY.
DILLON BACK TO PICK IT DEFENSIVE
ZONE.amie: YEP.
>> Gord:NTON REACHES FOR IT.
NOW BROUGHT I I
AND PICKED UP NOW B
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Gord: BRADY TKACHUK!
AND OTTAWA IS BACK
AND THE OTTAWA SENATORS HAVE
LIFE IN 3-2 EARLY IN THE THIRD .
GAVE TO SCHMIDTT
DEFLECTED WIDE BY -- NOW A NIKO.
IN.E CONNOR POWER PLAY GOAL!
AND THAT'S HIS
WHO IS REALLY WIDE, OUTSIDE THE
DOT, ALMOST BY THE BOARDS.
BUT HE GETS ENOUGH OF IT ON TEH.
EHLERS BACKHAND SHOT.
CONNOR.
DUBOIS, WRIST SHOT!
AND GETS
>> Gord: JOSEPH BACK.
STUTZLE SHORTHANDED.
SHOOTS.
K TO BRANNSTROM.
COLIN WHITE.
NOW TO POWER PLAY FOR
1:49.RADY TKACHUK WAITS FOR
THIS TO COME DOWN SO THAT
CROSS ICE OUT
ON TIM STUTZLE.